hey youtubers it's Charlie so Star Wars
Celebration was this past weekend they
announced a whole bunch of Star Wars
Episode 8 stuff that they're working on
right now
also they confirmed the new Han Solo so
this is gonna be my big reaction video
so the really interesting stuff we
learned that there isn't gonna be a time
jump so when we start with Episode eight
it will begin immediately as Rey is
meeting Luke Skywalker for the first
time that was actually the first
sequence that they shot they shot that
way before their main unit was ready to
shoot the rest of the film before they
finished casting all the new characters
in four they locked down the script for
the last time now they did explain that
Rian Johnson was developing episode 8 as
they were making Episode seven so as
they were shooting the force awakens
they were already working on Episode
eight but you know mostly the story
locking that down but for the most part
Rian Johnson wrote episode 8 he'll be
directing that he's always directing it
right now and he also wrote episode 9
but Colin Trevorrow who did Jurassic
world he's directing episode 9 so I'm
expecting some story beets for episode 9
- change - it's so far off they're still
developing that movie but you get the
idea they developed the next movie while
they're shooting the current movie so
the next major thing is is like the
focus of the film itself is a dig deeper
into its existing characters so like the
force awakens was meant to introduce you
into the new Star Wars Galaxies let you
know what it had been happening this
whole time how things had changed where
all the characters were now we're gonna
be learning more about them it'll be
more of a character focused movie so I
think it'll be a little more rewarding
if you're looking for a really deep dive
into Star Wars characters so kylo Ren
Carrie Fisher said the funniest thing
she's like Han and our son turned into
Hitler you can't help the feel bad about
that so we'll find out how that happened
how he felt abandoned because Han Solo
was such an adventure like he was really
hard to tie him down he was not suited
for family life so you can understand
how Ben grew up hearing about the
legends of the things that his family
had done in in feeling somewhat
inadequate so when feeling abandoned by
his father this new father figure was
able to swoop in and turn him to the
dark side so that's where Supreme Leader
Snoke comes in so we'll learn more about
that about the Knights of Ren we'll see
them both training Rey is kind of like
on this Jedi retreat at the original
Jedi Temple so we'll learn what Luke
Skywalker has been doing this whole time
he's been communing with the force
learning about it in a much deeper way
than he had before in the previous films
so whereas Episode seven is like the
intro course to the new Star Wars
universe
Episode eight is going to be the master
class so point of view character Rey is
going to be learning about her heritage
like she's been waiting for her family
this whole time we'll learn a little bit
more about her family Episode nine will
probably focus more on what she's going
to do with these new skills like pushing
the story forward there's still so much
backstory to fill in like even as late
as Return of the Jedi we were still
learning new things about the characters
backstories like oh my god Leia's my
sister so as much as we're going to get
immediate answers about what's going on
with the force with the battle with the
first order is going to look like
because there's still the resistance the
new republic was the thing that was
crushed in the force awakens those were
the planets that they've looked so now
you have this ragtag resistance in the
first order because there's really no
Empire anymore
so the odds are still insurmountable but
you can see how they're wiping the slate
clean the New Republic isn't going to be
like a crutch for Leia to lean on like
oh look at all these resources and all
these ships that we have I think they
just want to get away from that a little
and make the conflict feel a little more
personal but before I move on I'll say
spoiler warning for episode 7 if that
wasn't already obvious so Han Solo dies
in the film he's killed by kylo Ren his
son the way JJ Abrams talks about that
is that kylo Ren thought you know
somehow is wounded by this wicked act
those are kind of the words he used like
he was killing the rest of the light
side that was left in him but I think
it's ridiculous to assume that anybody
can be completely good or completely
evil I just did a rebels trailer video
where we meet a Bendu monk
which explains to one of the characters
there's the light side the dark side I'm
the one in the middle so you know very
clearly they're going to come to that
conclusion during the new movie trilogy
Luke Skywalker has probably been
learning about that like oh there is
more to the force than just the light
side and the dark side so Rey will
probably learn about that learn how to
use the Force in a more complete way
going into episode 9 where they'll make
the decisions about what the force in
the Jedi are going to look like going
forward in the franchise because they
will keep making Star Wars films the
Skywalker family is always going to be
important to the galaxy even if there
are a lot of other main characters like
even if Rey turns out to be the
if someone who is not a Skywalker but
when you think about the planets and the
locations that we saw during the force
awakens just expect that to be broadened
into Episode eight we're gonna learn
more about what's going on in the galaxy
beyond what the main characters have
been doing in the last film so that is
where characters like Poe Dameron and
Finn come in so like Finn won't be
travelling with Rey the whole time he
was left with the resistance when Rey
went to meet Luke Skywalker so she'll be
off learning about the force while Finn
will be learning about helping the
resistance so that will probably take us
a bunch of different places that we
haven't seen yet in the galaxy I know
episode 7 gets knocked a little for
being built such - template of the
original trilogy there was a cantina
scene where they just they built it out
with all these different aliens all of
them were new in some of them even
though they looked very elaborate were
just built to be background characters
they weren't meant to really have
backstories or anything like that but
just imagine that they all do have their
own story like will see more scenes like
that where they'll go the new planets
they'll meet new aliens they were
actually a bunch of new aliens that they
created for rogue one like space monkey
he was like the new fan favorite at Star
Wars Celebration so as much of this
story is about defeating kylo Ren or
redeeming him in defeating Supreme
Leader Snoke the things that the
resistance characters are doing will be
just as important and they're actually
way more resistance characters than
there are for sensitive characters like
you have Luke Rey kylo Ren Supreme
Leader Snoke in the Knights of Ren those
are about all we got in terms of force
sensitive characters right now we might
learn a little bit more about the Church
of the force that was actually like a
group of acolytes that this character
belonged to like they just called it the
Church of the force people that serve
the force like serve Luke Skywalker help
out but it'd be then obviously the
galaxy went to so that's kind of
gone sideways so there's like a whole
lot going on in the galaxy that goes
beyond what Luke Skywalker has been
doing this whole time even though that
will seem like the most important thing
like coming to this new grand
realization of the unifying force but
because episode 8 isn't coming out till
December 2017 I wouldn't expect a first
teaser till rogue one comes out like
once rogue one comes out I would expect
them to attach some footage to that so
just plan on them hammering down on
awesome Star Wars Episode eight stuff as
they ramp up for rogue one to come out
later this year but let me know what are
some of your guys biggest questions
about
Star Wars Episode 8 right now I know you
know most people want to know who arrays
parents are they Skywalker's where did
supreme leader snoke come from we'll
learn more about him and then you know
everybody wants to know what has Luke
Skywalker had been doing exactly this
whole time you know really the way
they've explained it so far is that he's
just been trying to learn more about the
nature of the force and he's gone back
to the original Jedi Temple to do that
and I would not be surprised if he
communicated that in a really obscure
infuriating way to Rey in the way the
obi-wan Kenobi told Luke Skywalker all
about his history without really
explaining everything up front like they
did have that conversation later on
where Luke was like why didn't you tell
me all these things and he was like well
you weren't you weren't ready to know
like if you knew your father was Darth
Vader you would have gone running off to
him before you learned how evil he was
so I wouldn't be surprised if there were
some shades of that with Luke
Skywalker's relationship with Rey like
he explains things to her but he doesn't
explain everything up front oh and I
almost forgot they confirmed alton
Ehrenreich as the new Han Solo so the
Han Solo spin-off film will be
20-something Han Solo do you know used
to look at the age of the actor you can
imagine how old he's gonna be in the
movie so that will probably be the story
of how he met Chewbacca some of their
early adventures together it'll be a lot
of fun he's actually a pretty good actor
so just trust the Lucasfilm casting to
part like the person that cast the Star
Wars films is the same person that cast
for Game of Thrones in some of the other
biggest productions with the best actors
in the last couple of years really the
big question for that is what the story
will actually end up being I'm totally
not worried about the actors or anything
like that I'm sure that'll be great
it's really what the actual story is
going to be but it's going to be a fun
adventure that'll just kind of exist on
its own that will also be canon to the
rest of the films if you're not sure
about what's Canon what's not Canon
everything that is being produced after
Disney bought Star Wars so like rebels
everything from the TV shows the books
will be canon to the main series so just
address comic-con a lot of you have
asked if there's gonna be Star Wars
stuff happening at Comic Con if there is
it's really just going to be specific to
the TV show they just had Star Wars
Celebration so most of the stuff that
they were gonna do they did at that
convention so I'm not expecting any new
trailers any new footage from rogue
or episode eight or anything like that
the big stuff at Comic Con is mostly
going to be movies TV shows like Marvel
DC Game of Thrones Walking Dead so be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
there's any other Star Wars videos that
you guys want me to do just let me know
most of the Star Wars stuff that I'm
planning on doing will be later this
year is like they start to ramp up for
rogue one to come out it's gonna be a
really good film but they're definitely
designing it to look unique from the
other Star Wars films while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my Star Wars Episode 8
teaser video like the little teaser that
they posted earlier this year and you
can click here to learn all about the
Batman family coming onto the CW TV
shows this season thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight